la Coupe du monde de rugby débute dans
une semaine on va vous détailler le
programme des festivités prévues à Tours
pour l'occasion mais avant direction
l'aéroport de Tours car ça y est
l'équipe d'Irlande tant attendue est
arrivée en Touraine son camp de base les
joueurs et leur staff ont atterri en
début d'après-midi presque en catiminé
et ce sont dirigés directement vers le
château Belmont où il résideront
reportage de Lucas Chopin et Florent
Clavel
on aurait pu s'attendre à une plus
grande fête l'équipe de rugby d'Irlande
est arrivée à Tours en toute discrétion
seuls quelques jeunes femmes attendaient
l'avion à son atterrissage un peu avant
15h
et de voir les internationaux qu'on aime
de cyprès j'ai trouvé apercevoir
Jonathan SIXTON pour d'autres c'est
arrivé était aussi l'occasion de mêler
curiosités et passion de l'aviation en
fait c'est par une application qui
permet de traquer les avions et donc
j'ai vu qu'il arrivait à l'aéroport de
Tours aujourd'hui et donc j'ai pu suivre
en direct le vol et voir qu'il arrivait
moi je suis là je suis l'aéronautique je
suis passionné et donc là je peux voir
l'avion de l'équipe d'Irlande et
l'équipe d'Irlande dans son bus
peut-être après avoir posé le pied à
tour c'est sous l'escorte du raid que
les Irlandais se sont rendus au château
Belmont c'est ici qu'il prendront leur
quartier pendant le Mondial
si l'arrivée de l'équipe n'a pas déplacé
les foules il se peut que les supporters
se mobilisent lors des entraînements au
stade de la chambreerie problème des
bâches cachent la vue des joueurs depuis
l'extérieur sauf peut-être pour quelques
privilégiés ça fait plaisir franchement
j'adore le rugby pourquoi pas on peut
c'est derrière chez nous par contre ils
sont tous
ils sont tous cachés pour sur le terrain
mais nous par contre on peut voir le
deuxième étage de chez nous moi je suis
très heureux qui viennent moi je suis au
Premier League pourquoi parce que j'ai
la chance d'avoir une fenêtre sur pignon
et je crois bien que je suis le seul je
suis aux premières loges
je suis un peu privilégié là-dessus
les Irlandais ont maintenant quelques
jours de répit devant eux avant leur
premier match samedi 9 septembre face à
la Roumanie